[موسيقى]
البعض يعتبره اسطوره في التصوير انه
المصور الراحل فاروق ابراهيم الذي التقط
بعدسته اهم احداث مصر على مدار 60 سنه
وانفرد بلقطات للنجوم والمشاهير في حياتهم
اليوميه
[موسيقى]
كل صوره هنا وراءها حكايه لا تنسى حكاها
فاروق ابراهيم لاولاده
[موسيقى]
هو ابتدى فكره مصاحبه الفنانين بعبد
الحليم حافظ ده كان اول حد صاحبه ده كان
فكر من عبد الحليم وتقدم جدا من دماغ عبد
الحليم حافظ الفنان العظيم كل صوره صوره
فاروق ابراهيم وراها حكايه طويله جدا يعني
لو بصينا على الصوره دي الصوره دي خدت ست
شهور محاوله اقناع بس النجيب محفوظ علشان
يرضى يتصور
[موسيقى]
شيرين رضا عليها صوره وهي صغيره كانت
بتروح التدريبات بتاعه فرقه رضا وكانت
مهتمه جدا وكانت بتركز وهي صغيره اهي وهي
اللي مشاركه معاهم على طول بالروح ومشاركه
معاهم اه
البنونه دي على الطبله
[موسيقى]
ربطته صداقه بمعظم نجوم ومشاهير مصر في
النصف الثاني من القرن العشرين دخل بيوتهم
وشاركهم اهم احداث حياتهم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جدا جدا فقالت انا خلاص انا عايزاه
وعايزاه يبقى المصور بتاعي اول ما شافته
قالت له انا عايز الصور التقليديه المستوى
الفنان ما ياكلش ما يشربش ما تظهرش اي
جانب بس انت نفسك ليا قالت له لا لو كده
يبقى مش هنصور اول ما ابتدا يصور الجانب
الشخصي والضحك ولقيت الاقبال على الصور ان
هي ابتدا يبقى ليها الجمهور من الشباب
اكتر ابتدى سابت له بقى المجال كله
وهنا عبد الحليم نايم في بيته عادي ده كده
راجع من الحفله خلاص خلص خالص اه دي من
كتر النومه دي عبد الحليم كان يرجع هو
النوم كان بيخاف جدا ينام بالليل فهيفضل
قاعد على السرير كده مستلقي يريح لحد ما
النور يطلع الناس تصحى في البيت ساعتها
يبتدي ينام
[موسيقى]
ارشيف النادر لفاروق ابراهيم يعرض هنا
لاول مره للجمهور ضمن فعاليات اسبوع
القاهره للصوره او كايرو فوتويك احنا
السنه دي هدفنا ان احنا نرجع بالشباب ان
هم يرجعوا يشوفوا اصل الحرفه هنا في مصر
كانت عامله ازاي وفاروق ابراهيم مش مهواش
مدرسه محليه بس هو فعليا هو مدرسه دوليه
يعني المفروض بيدرس في الجامعات بره
والده هو الفضول والشغف لالتقاط الصوره